chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett is here with more on the debate
we are voters there candidates would
take your point exactly on not being a
theater critic but let's talk about some
of the issues the economy and McRae's
immigration health care key points pored
over by all the candidates are those
issues that Democrats can win on in 2020
well certainly health care help them win
in 2018 but what was clear last night as
health care is not a settled issue it's
a priority but Medicare for all divided
some of that feel that it's probably
gonna divide them again tonight private
insurance do you want to keep it or do
you want to eradicate it now Elizabeth
Warren gave it an answer said yes I'm
willing to do it and here's why well she
becomes the nominee then you can that's
gonna be the consensus for the
Democratic Party but this is not a
settled issue it's a priority they won
with it in 2018 but when you get deeper
into specifics you find divisions look
at immigration I think because I spent a
lot of time when the Trump world for the
last four years when who Leon Castro has
a breakout night but says illegal
border-crossing should be a civil
offense not a criminal one Trump
supporters will say are you kidding me
what was 2016 all about and the Trump
campaign will look at that and say if
that becomes democratic orthodoxy bring
it on well in fact the Trump world as
you mentioned the Trump campaign said
last night was the best case possible
for the re-election of President Trump
lots of issues and they will also say
Democrats simply do not understand the
economic reality they could consistently
complain the economy is not working for
everyone but the Trump reelection
campaign would say it's working better
than it has in a long time and there are
statistics to back it up one major one
conspicuous thing last night none of the
10 candidates on the stage even
mentioned the front-runner of exactly
not even a glancing reference to maybe a
different kind of bipartisanship or a
generational shift yeah Joe Biden has to
figure out why is that because they
think he is foundering and they want to
leave him to that or they think his
support is broad but thin and is not
that relevant I think Joe Biden tonight
has to look at that stage and say
there's an opportunity but I've got to
have some dynamism I've got to make sure
people understand I don't think this is
a coronation and I'm not going to be
cautious about this frontrunner status
one of the biggest things that hurts
frontrunners over time is looking at is
if it's a coronation or you're so
cautious about the
lead you have I think tonight that's
gonna be interesting factor nine other
candidates including Joe Biden take to
the stage tonight do you think they have
an advantage because they got to see
last night and can you explain again why
got to go first and who got to go second
so the DNC did this by lottery you had
to meet a threshold to qualify twenty
candidates did then they did it by
lottery what night and what position so
as not to appear to be doing anything to
pre-bake who appears when or where on
stage that's point one as for an
advantage the second night we've seen
how the moderators go you've seen the
flow of conversation that's an advantage
but I think the looking audience might
be a little bit lower tonight because
four hours is a lot of time to commit
even if you're a democratic Apple though
it's interesting I mean like my 23 year
old daughter watch the entire two hours
yeah she wanted to see all of it you
mentioned earlier that Elizabeth Warren
got a lot of the questions early on yeah
early on but the New York Times did add
it all up and said actually cory booker
and better work spoke the most did did
that have an impact do you think well
for cory booker out what i was most
interested in and this is just an
objective fact every time you gave an
answer he talked about my community
meaning i'm from an urban part of New
Jersey I moved there early it's part of
my being yeah not just my politics in a
place like South Carolina where was last
week the Booker campaigns doing well
that reference to I'm a person of color
I have lived in difficult neighborhoods
I've seen people killed by gun violence
real long has that personalization put
together with a policy platform can and
historically has been effective all
right major we will no longer make any
judgments like you always do all the
judge major after I'm left the room but
will here very I love it when you say we
love to have you here Thank You major
Garrett